you've probably slept right through the
second government shutdown of the new
year it came and went overnight but just
like before the temporary solution comes
with an expiration date not too far in
the future correspondent Peter Doocy is
on Capitol Hill tonight to tell us about
this new deal and some major
backpedaling by the GOP reopening the
government required a big reversal for
Republicans here's why back in 2011 when
President Obama wanted to raise the debt
ceiling
Republicans required him to impose
budget caps to harness spending mr.
president we will we will raise the debt
ceiling literally if you agree to cut up
the credit cards but this morning
Republicans wanted to freeze the debt
ceiling and they made a deal that got
rid of those cats to do it don't you
remember when Republicans how to high
heaven that President Obama was spending
us into the gutter spending us into
oblivion
president Trump blames the balance of
power tweeting today quote without more
Republicans in Congress we were forced
to increase spending on things we do not
like or want in order to finally after
many years of depletion take care of our
military sadly we needed some dem votes
for passage must elect more republicans
in 2018 election today he signed a bill
that keeps the government funded till
March 23rd then over two years spends
six billion dollars fighting opioid
addiction puts twenty billion toward
infrastructure and repeals Obamacare
Independent Payment Advisory Board but
the lack of restraint has prominent
conservatives furious
there's not even any pretense here and
balancing a budget on paper it's hard to
believe the bipartisan Budget Act of
2018 was endorsed by the same budget
committee chair who cut this 2011 video
we will cut and speaker Ryan insists
there are some things even the most
responsible fiscal Hawks can't plan for
most of this domestic spending as you
pointed out is one-time spending it's
it's hurricane relief I mean what we're
not gonna rebuild houston we're not
going to rebuild Florida we're not gonna
help Puerto Rico or the fires in
California after a late night most
lawmakers
left in and then went home but in a
mostly empty capital today I did see the
White House legislative affairs director
mark short who said he was here for
meetings with Republican offices about
daca short told me that next week daca
talks are really going to pick up ahead
of the deportation deadline in 24 days
Chris Peter Doocy on an empty Capitol
Hill Peter thank you